[Music]
hello everybody and we are live please
don't swear um that's what he was saying
at the radio please answer
um you can swear
welcome and good evening and we are
going to have our first ever quiz night
on our little sidetrack channel and
tonight this quiz is about star trek
specifically the next generation but
there is a round on general sci-fi which
captain spencer who outranks me little
turd
um has um
we'll do all right there's a doctor who
questions me
so yes
sweet
so i will very quickly introduce my
friends here so
on her side here we have stormy from
cyworks channel um he is the
illegitimate love child of thor the god
of thunder and the care bear
yes and that is me
and he is our token american for this
exactly directly underneath me is mikey
um what stupid thing do i write down for
mikey let's have a look oh his proudest
moment is when he bit slapped will
wheaton
i've got that there and because
and he has a massive geek he's probably
going to win this but it's only really
between him and stormy if we're honest
because we've got spencer now when i
came to do the silly little thing about
introducing spencer i didn't have to
make anything up
this is a man and when we did a live
show decided to do trill markings on his
face and did it with a permanent marker
and then got drunk and fell off his
chair
so
after falling
down
yeah it is why i love you i did a video
exactly saying that me
so in this quiz this evening we are
going to have four rounds
at the start of each round we're going
to have a a wrong answers only question
just a bit of silliness and then we've
got four rounds
the rounds will be who what where why
who what why where even
getting technical the movies and a
general sci-fi question
within these questions there is a sneaky
little wrong answer question where there
is actually multiple answers to the
question
if you can identify that you get some
juicy bonus points if you can explain it
to me you get even more bonus
points um if you are watching with us
please play along but
as i'm going to ask
there we go
tell us your scores at the end please
but try not to put the scores in the um
in the comments because these three will
cheat
and um we want to see if you can beat
the panel that is the one we will eat
like [ __ ] yeah we will that's that's
actually true
yeah
it's not even we're not even pretending
that's that's completely no no
please
yeah throw your scores out at the end
because i really want to see what people
get if anything
i've we've got a mixed bag here guys
i've tried to make a couple ones easy
suspense can actually get involved and
put some of them
um
some of them
i thought this was on dragon ball z
is that even
just watching dragon ball z for the last
month yeah preparing for this quiz
all right then so we'll just get stuck
in
at the end of each round we'll go
through the answers you will tell me
your scores and we will basically see
how we get on
so before we start anything though wrong
answers only
and the first question wrong answers
only what is the most popular holodeck
program aboard starfleet vessels
throw them out
the
simulation videos
the three sticks
how do you play latrine sticks
simulation
the latrine simulation uh holodeck uh
programs those are the most popular
yeah yeah
anything with the safety protocols
disengaged there there's a whole lot of
floaters down there in the in the
klingon latrine simulation
i wonder what klingon toilets would be
like
have you seen their food
very large guy i would say
dear god that would be disgusting what's
this
no wonder there's no toilets on these
starships
imagine a klingon one
dear god how about you mikey
the plunger also serves as a shield
i would also say probably data trying to
learn about humans
from computer humans
i like that so i think the thing i
always loved about star trek was on in
the tv series they pretend that the
hollow deck is all about training
and maybe going to pretty planets
quark was just it's all about sex
they're all really dirty you have to
wipe down the hollow deck after every
and you have to pay for it
yep if you put a black light in there
it'd be like a pollock and it's just
awful in
there all right let's let's get on to
the quiz
who what where and why
so pens are ready
excellent
first question
spence um you're going to know this one
stormy you mentioned it earlier name the
being that killed tashia and this is the
first time we see
mikey's got an answer
or he's having a poo
he's definitely pulling a face of one of
those two things
i am done with my answer answer i knew
stormy would know this one okay well
here's a slightly contentious one
which vessel survived the battle of wolf
359
she was
found repaired and
rejoin saves
i'll give you a clue i'm not looking
forward to trying to pronounce it
okay
you've got an answer
you're not googling this well i've got
an answer
did you want me to i still no no don't
tell us jesus
i know spencer's face i know he has an
answer for this but i do not
bonus question here quickly for a bonus
point
how many ships were destroyed in the
battle of war 359
you're a jerk
these questions are
horrible
i didn't want them to be easy
it can't be how many times did
beverly crush a shagger ghost it can't
be that it's gotta be more difficult
all right question number three
i was terrible
number three the how many survive the
battle
now that was a bonus question so that's
a
question
okay i need another card gotcha okay
question number three who beats up riker
in the episode conspiracy
beats the crap out of him
okay this is the first easy one and
spencer you don't get this
i am going to come and slap you
so here you go which 137 year old
admiral inspected the enterprise in the
episode encounter at far point
don't you know that one come on
goku
goku
is that dragon ball z i've never watched
it i don't
i'm not gonna know that reference that's
pretty good
question number five which famous prop
in star trek the next generation was
originally just a hairband and an air
filter
can you repeat that one again oh don't
that was an easy one
which famous prop
in star trek the next generation was
originally just a hair band and a filter
an air filter
that's what they used to make it
you're going to kick yourself mikey it's
really yours
yeah you are going to just leave the
stream
oh god
it was also used in the dune movie
good thing he's the same one okay
i'm glad to see my [ __ ] teeth here
i'm the american remember
yeah he's not yeah we've got to beat the
american guys come on
question number six deanna troy nearly
had three what
good lines
i love jana troy come on marina searches
what did patrick stewart really hate
about the cards ready room
oh right yeah
yeah
this video has a lot of um
just anguished faces on top of heads
desperately writing answers there should
we put the answers on top of our heads
you can do
question number eight
what was the enterprise d's the
enterprise d's sister ship named
it's sister
ship give you a clue it's u.s.s
i'm not telling anyone
question number nine are we keeping up
guys
question number nine
when picard was captured by the
kardashians four lines
sorry absolutely that's my acting billy
um who commanded the enterprise while he
was away
well he was away that makes it sound
like he was on holiday well he's having
a lovely little trip away with the
kardashians counting lights
who captained the enterprise
[Music]
i finally know an answer
yeah i love i love those episodes great
great two-parter
hanging out again
question 10 and this is a two-parter for
a bonus i'm still writing down question
nine answer
always waiting for the americans
just be quiet
okay the answer is
excellent okay question number ten
two-parter
when was the enterprise d launched
and i got got you've got a choice here
it was either 2372
2363
2299 or 2401
can you say those again
23 63 22 99 doing a different order
22.99
23.72
or 2401
when was the enterprise launched
enterprise d launched
okay
bonus question
when was she destroyed
but i'm not giving you any things for
that one what was it the 23
you got 23.72
2363
2299 or 2401
that's when she was launched
and then when was she destroyed
let me know when you've got your answers
and i will tell you the correct ones
i'm ready when you are
everybody else ready
are we happy
d are you going to round robin and ask
us what our answers are or are you just
going to give them to us
should we go around
we'll go around
okay but you're going to be honest you
can't just
mike
half a point wrong
spencer
i put i just put tar guy
okay
our guy's name was armas
the correct answer is arms of course
um
yeah if anybody gets this one i'm
genuinely going to be impressed
and which vessels
survive the battle of wolf 359
mikey you're first what did you put i
did i didn't put an answer not a bloody
clue
no stormy
the cerritos
i'm afraid it was not the series
uh the credit roll for
uh lower down
you see it go up to work three five nine
it gets zapped and then it leaves
your friends off you are not wrong it
survives that is the battle 359 and not
another battle i do we know it's all
three fish now it is yes because you see
the other ships were destroyed in the
cannon
i don't think it is because they're
wearing they're already wearing ds9
uniforms by that point and and and wall
359 was
bathroom standard
uniforms but spencer that you know this
then what was the vessel that survived i
i've got a question
because i don't know what answered it
but
was it the ship that cisco escaped from
no because that was destroyed that was
completely destroyed oh i didn't okay
the ship that survived was the owani
it was the only ship that supposedly
survived there is some sun saying that
possibly also the endeavour survived but
that isn't
sort of a
cannon sort of thing but possibly the
endeavour survived as well
but the iwani is the fishland to protect
my uh lower decks uh reference there's
an episode of lower decks where there
are different crews that are wearing
different uniform styles in the same
timeline
thank you dude i think they like poke
fun that's true are we going to say
though that lower decks is canon
because i'm not sure it is
but anyway we'll move on i i would argue
that it is
okay
i would storm the point give storm the
point okay
i'm not giving him a point i'm being
strict and i'm the quiz master so
right the bonus question how many ships
were destroyed in the battle
you should know
will i give my answer for africa who's
first going to stormy yep
loads
it was 39 ships guys 39.
i am guaranteeing that he was annoying
this knew that
okay well you know if you don't got
these ones you're definitely not getting
this one who beats a breiken episode of
conspiracy
i might take a general
description here go on spence
the old admiral
i'll take that old admiral
what did you guys write mike
where did i put wolf
no
no
stormy
well i know the episode my answer is so
wrong i don't even want to reveal it
okay
because i'm thinking a completely
different episode
i put the guards on god
you know riker's kind of like the
punching bag of an episode you know it's
just
you know
as far as that's close part of the story
let's go send somebody in to beat up
riker
if mine was wrong it was just horrible
but you should just
i will ignore it the old admiral guy the
beta breaker was admiral gregory quinn
there you go so which hundred special
seven-year-old admiral
inspected the the enterprising encounter
at farpoint
mike
i didn't put an answer for this one
oh come on
yeah at this point his career he was
brittle bones just not bones you
it was just eighth hip replacement that
day so you know
i can't believe i didn't get that one
how did you remember that he's got all
that horrible fake makeup ons making i
can't believe i didn't remember that
we can't believe you didn't remember
that i'm embarrassed for you like i'm
just gonna put it down to
i don't know
bad company
[Laughter]
question number five which prop
was originally just a hair band and an
air filter
stormy you knew this one
turtle forge is
i feel stupid now
join mikey no no answer
no
i i'm annoyed
you told me you told me every girl i i
was dating in high school had one of
those how could anybody
i mean you know
yeah it was very clearly there bandwidth
okay so fun question
deanna troy nearly had three what
boob
nope
stormy
no
their nose must have been rikers captain
spencer do you know this little tidbit
yeah boo boo intended
sorry
boobers tits
she merely had
three boobies
what did patrick stewart hate about his
picard's ready room
mikey
windows
nope
no i'm ready
i think i'm right the fish tank the fish
tank
stop spence damn it i've i wrote down no
idea and then i remembered that it was
the fish and that's why i was like oh oh
and i was gonna say can i change my
answer but storms storms beating me to
punch faster no i i used to
i got told you know the reason you know
the this whole series with the um
with the badly designed costumes where
he kept on pull the classic picard pull
down
i i read somewhere that he kept doing
that because he kept looking in the
window which was actually a mirror on
the set and it reminded him that he kept
riding up so he kept him to do that he
hated it so i'm actually right
well i've not heard that but i have um
as i say he has said in interviews
repeatedly that he hated the fish tank
in the ready room because he doesn't he
he felt it was like
captaincy
didn't like it would your fishing space
well yeah exactly but he thought it was
very
not very mod of them
um
do you give him a point for that but
i've not heard that story so we're gonna
have to i might have to throw it out to
the air give me half a point at one
point in time stewart was doing an
off-broadway play of like he'd play a
little bit apart a little part of
everything he'd ever done in theater
but he didn't do any star trek stuff at
the very last he sat down on a stool
and pulled his shirt down and then
everybody applauded and he couldn't
figure out why everybody applauded so he
asked
one of the stage hands what everybody
plus well you pulled your shirt down
just like you do
i love that i love that that's awesome
i was just going to say another bit of
trivia it's why it's also part of the
reason why in series five he stops
wearing the uniform whilst everyone else
continues and he starts wearing a jacket
and that was partly due to even the new
uniforms they made he considered too
uncomfortable um and he wanted to stand
out from a crowd so they modified it and
it actually had
gorgeousness
where it had different shoulders for
jacket in darmoch that it did to the
rest of the episode they read it's like
a suede material i've always wanted one
i'm like i'm not really i'm not really
into buying new uniforms and like
getting dressed up and stuff but i have
one of those
those uniforms are made out of velour
that they've turned inside out
oh i wish that was one of the questions
it isn't
question number eight
who well what was the enterprise d's
sistership
well i think i've got this
which is amazing considering i've got
every other question wrong and why my
brain came back to this as being
something it pulled out of the brain is
it the uss yamoto
it is the uss yomoto well done
stormy do you get an answer
v excellent
once if you got the d you've got to have
the v i'm just saying that's a total you
know heteroerotic statement i realized
with the v why i got that i don't know
that's amazing
how about you spence what did you get oh
i i just took a stab in the dark i just
put the stargazer because i know that
was the ship the car was on before
but
well there you go that was his first
first command
when picard was captured by the
kardashians four lights
who commanded the enterprise
if you get this i'll be impressed as
well
it's called angelico
it was captain jericho
delico i should say
it was his obvious answer
yeah and stormy
i had admiral that had the illegal ship
that re-emerged in an asteroid
what points
uh did picard go on that away mission
and why did jericho take over the the i
can explain that i can explain that they
they wanted they wanted picard to
infiltrate with the
with the kardashians whilst also having
a
a different
diplomatic style of captain which is why
jelico is the first person who made troy
wear the regular uniform
and then the admiral you're thinking of
is riker's old captain from his previous
command
from the uh i want to say pegasus
episode that's not right is it that was
pegasus wasn't it i think it was for the
facebook look at that one
riker's old dude was those were those
were different no no because jellicoe
and reich had only met in um in the in
the the episode where jericho comes in
and they did not get on this isn't the
same yeah it isn't the same no i got
that completely all wrong
okay
well
final two there's two points
when was the enterprise d launched
spence looks so so hopeful
63 2363
it is 23.63
that is correct stormy what you get
22.99 i failed
wrong mikey
i got 22 uh 23.63 i'm shoved a [ __ ]
myself on that one excellent
and it means i think i've got the last
one right
so when was she destroyed
23.72
you're close
i'm going to give you that
i'm going to get that
yeah
it's 23.71
i didn't realize we had oh i didn't
realize we had to put a date down i just
put generations
you're not wrong
that's how that's the point either but
you're not wrong that's that's right it
was destroyed in generations
questions when like when a kid goes uh
tell us where x is and the kid describes
it's here and draws an arrow pointing
back at the answer the question you just
said was it destroyed generations
yeah that's not a point in time though
is it
maybe um but anyway stormy
anyway quizmaster wrong
stormy what put what you coming
for the uh for the year
yeah
yeah 22.99 i totally host it ah
unlucky okay right scores on the doors
after the first round
taking a shocking lead i think i i think
we're all
amazed
is our spencer with five
points coming up
quickly behind him is our stormy
and mikey both with three points
well done
that is shocking i'm
i'm disappointed
move on
to what i consider to be the hard
questions
they're getting technical
oh no
actually
i will say that stormy for the first uh
what is the most popular holodeck
program for the starfleet vessel stormy
most definitely gets
the bonus point for his answer
i i look down and mikey's gone
well he's off to clean the uh klingon
latrine
exactly it will be gone for the rest of
night then so the wrong answer's only
question for this round please is
describe ways data is fully functional
wrong answers only
because we know how he's fully
functioning on a dirty little yellow
fella
we can have those answers at the end
have a think about it and we'll have
them at the end okay
so
we're gonna wait for mikey to come back
is he having a pool
are you guys ready to
answer questions
in iso tons
here he is he's back
yes to answer your question
so the um wrong answers only question
for this round will which will give the
answer to the end is describe ways which
data is fully functional
getting technical question number one
are we ready pens after ready
pins at the ready
excellent
first question nice and easy one to ease
you in
how many decks does the enterprise d
have
straight in spence spence you have been
swatting
excellent right here's enough here's a
is an evil one
what is the yield maximum practical
yield
of a standard photon torpedo
in isotons
and i'll give you with i'll give you a
bit of a big leeway here of a
one one or two points i'll give you a
point
is it is this uh series specific
it's mentioned in voyager and a couple
of times and it's mentioned in tng at
least twice
but it's also in all the technical
manuals okay i think i'm getting it
confused my brain is getting it confused
with the cobalt device okay i think i'm
gonna miss that
bonus question how
what is the yield in megatons if it was
equivalent to a nuclear weapon what is
it in megatons
[Music]
and again i'll give you five either way
for that if you get close enough
five
this round is hard
i don't know what i might just give a
point to whoever gets closest to do that
never gets closest i think i might have
got that one right
amazing
well here's a nice easy one
here's a nice easy one
where would i find a heisenberg
compensator
[Music]
spencer knows
he's just trying to hold on to that lead
man
oh sorry sorry sorry
guys like being at school gonna wait for
the slogan
[Music]
this isn't exactly roughly
how fast in kilometers per hour is warp
nine
you have a choice
900 billion kilometers an hour 70
billion kilometers an hour
seven trillion kilometers an hour or 800
billion
kilometers an hour
so how fast is warp nine in kilometers
now this is said in an episode where
riker actually says it and it's
obviously from the technical manuals as
well
but now this is question four yeah 900
billion 70 billion seven trillion or
eight hundred billion wait
i've got five written down
um because we had the bonus question of
the isotons
that's why i got confused as well it's
all good i think i've worked it out
okay i only actually number five
if we're ready question number five i'll
tell you the question as we go along
what was the safe maximum speed of the
enterprise d
in warp
in warp yeah
now in miles an hour
if you put it in miles an hour you get
five bonus points
a bonus point for question number five
what was the enterprise ease
maximum safe
speed
in what
enterprise
and surprise e
again i think i've got this you want to
circuit this around me
also this is just like guesswork
here's a little bit unless you're a
complete geek and read the manual
um question number six due to the use of
heavy warp what did the enterprise need
a stronger than usual sweep of
squeak off what was that sweet off
sweet
in an episode let's go in for a service
and they had to have a sweep
of this
energy field so when he went
and
interesting fact two vox actor was in
that tim ross played a yeah
you go you asked but can you remember
the name of the sweep
yes i believe i've got it
go on monkey go on
right
dolphins crew the enterprise we all know
this
what is the name of their department
can you repeat the question
dolphins
crew the enterprise there are dolphins
aboard the enterprise acting as crew
what is the name of their department
or their um
i think it's called operations but what
is the name of it
i bet it's walled with clear aluminum
aluminum for stormy
clear aluminum walls the enterprise
the enterprise d has them but also we do
see it on lower decks
not the hms bounty but the enterprise
yes let's go with that
we also see it in lower decks and the
operations or department is called the
same thing
[Music]
not watch lower decks i really wish i
had
i told you to watch it
i watched it on your prime account
no worries thanks for login
we don't we don't do that really amazon
we're honest playing customers
yeah exactly don't admit that in like
bloody journey
we we live in the same office
yes you do
so number question number eight and
there is a bonus question to this as
well but question number eight
what is the name of the captain's yacht
on the enterprise d
and this is according to patrick stewart
what is the name of the captain's yacht
on the enterprise d
oh i think i know it
oh you might know the bonus question
then because it's related ah
i know it
well done
is what is the enterprise e captain
yacht called
oh it might have been that
say it twice
oh no i've got this wrong
i know i have it wrong
i think i think i've got it right and
that's really sad
it's not you're the quizzes
well if i got this right then this is
sad
i'll be impressed
question number nine
according to data and he says this
during the episode day today
um how many species are represented on
the enterprise d
yeah how many
alien species including humans are
represented on the enterprise
he talks about
an average day there's four birthdays
two things two today and he says how
many oh
we'll get a point for closest
okay and
and then nice easy one kind of a
technical question without this really
how long
is the enterprise e and again closest
how long does the enterprise e
picard tells you in first contact
yeah he does
and if you weren't listening it's your
own fault in his room with all the
little ships
he does you broke your little ships
but like i said closest will get a point
no
how much of it ended up in tom hardy's
face
[Laughter]
about
20 minutes 30 minutes 40 years old
that's helped me work out the length
thanks for that jamie exactly
just have the time
so
round two first of all what were your
answers for the wrong answers only
question don't forget there's a bonus
point describe ways data is fully
functional
throwback
i'd say okay mine is oh you got it sorry
no you get you go storm you got in the
first round
mine is he can do both uh standard and
metric
jesus that's a superpower never mind her
fully functional go on this spence
i i just said he's fully functional by
also being dysfunctional
oh
that's big blue thinking
okay i like it
it's on my inside right side i don't
know how about you mikey you got an
answer i would say he's very good at
playing classical music inappropriate
times
at inappropriate times
yes
i imagine that he can attach things to
his belly button
like like you know uh like attachments
so like a hoover attachment and things
like that but i might have stolen that
off another show
but um i i think stormy is getting that
again guys
he's just funnier than youtube that was
that was funny i enjoyed that
so stormy is getting the bonus point on
that one so right i think you might need
it for this one
so getting technical question number one
how many decks does the enterprise d
have
mike
i've gone for 24.
it's it's wrong though is the enterprise
d i'm afraid
stormy
32 i don't i don't even know how close i
am you're closer suspense
36 like me
i'm afraid it's 42 decks
as closest do i get a point
not on this one because you really
should know that
yes
the wrong way around the funny thing is
before this quiz discussed how many
decks a couple of days ago so we both
should have known that oh well there's a
there's another question coming up but
in case you might know
what is the maximum yield the closest is
going to get a point for this what is
the maximum yield practical usable yield
of a standard photon torpedo in iso tons
my turn
spence
1200
and stormy 50.
mike gets the point the answer is
actually 18.5 i certainly don't you go
mike
so
what
bonus point can you figure that out in
megatons four hundred thousand
spence
twelve hundred
i can't stop it
i have one thousand megatons and no idea
lots stormy wins that one but you're all
massively out it's 64 megatons
so um
but in voyager they talk about getting a
photon torpedo up to 45 50 iso tons and
which is just completely out of
everything that's ever said in star trek
before that
but so no points there i'm afraid oh no
sorry yeah so i've got a point storm we
got the bonus point for being closest
massively wrong
i've got the point as well on
i didn't the um
closer yeah you've got the point as well
there so you want to mikey two to stormy
nothing spent so far
um
where would i find a heisenberg
compensator
stormy
transporter room and it's near the ford
power assembly
very nice i almost want to give you a
bonus point but i'm not going to mikey
i think it's in data's head
and spence
i just put engineering
no it isn't an engineering i'm afraid
stormy is correct it's in the
transporters and because still we have a
physics background we could probably
explain what a heisenberg compensator is
but don't it's boring
um so there you go
how fast in kilometers we're on question
number four how fast in kilometers per
hour is warp nine
stormy come on stormy first
i have no idea so i wrote out the
formulas according to some people who
estimate what
it is in star trek so it's the ninth log
of the speed of light
excellent and mike
see what i actually gave your choice of
four answers and one of them was correct
stormy
i put 800 billion
okay and spence
900 billion
spencer gets the point it is 900 billion
kilometers an hour
um what was the safe maximum speed of
the enterprise d this isn't the cruising
speed this is the maximum safe
speed go on mikey
five
five oh you're trying to be clever
but it isn't
the vessel was capable of doing warp
much higher than that there wasn't it oh
i know that but no the safe
no there's something that's described
the thing and then they fixed that
anyway didn't they for the films so they
started they just put speed limit in
for a few years okay so your bonus one
right which was for the e
the safe speed was warp seven
even though you could do much higher
than that
all right okay but you're arguing that
that's because it damages the fabric of
space without it they compensated for it
didn't they
ask them
questions okay i say though that
what is it speed of my car
it's
140 miles an hour but it was just really
70 though because that's the maximum
speed limit
also mike this is this is this is next
gen and up until the movies so they have
compensated for them but aren't you
going
uh spin on it you know there's things
called v speeds
you know you're talking about you know v
of c which is the velocity of cruise
versus c of never exceed which is v of n
e
i think god what did you answer story
what did you put what answer did you put
me
9.2
9.2 i think you're gonna have to get a
point from being closest for the
enterprise uh d
it was 9.6 oh
for the enterprise e it was what 9.95
is the safest maximum speed
i didn't put the points can i get can i
get a point for nine
come on that was my dispenser's close
and stormy's closer so i'm going to give
you one point stormy for that one thank
you thank you
that's still a good shout out all of
america
so where are the dolphins aboard the
enterprise d what is the name of their
department well you missed
you're all right question number six
what is the name of the
sweep that they do due to high warp
suspense
was it a tacky on sweep
no
monkey
i put that they brought the binars in
uh i think that's what's going on i
think it's on the other computer
we thought you would say no
[Music]
the periodic table but
i've had so much trouble with the
periodic table this week i don't want to
discuss it
so what is the name of where the
dolphins
are
based worked whatever they work and live
in the same place they don't even get
their own crew quarters it's such a
[ __ ] but what is the name of it
mikey got an answer
i'll put section 21 but i know that's
wrong
yes that is wrong so spencer
i just put poor person
poor person now i'm afraid not stormy
cetacean division
he gets the point
see the thing is i was thinking okay the
dolphins was part of the you know uh the
one of the films and he was like when
they're bringing they had a possession
of the uh klingon warbird and scotty
renamed it the hms
uh
bounty because they were committing
mutiny but they had to go back and then
say well was it really the mutiny or is
he talking about enterprise and so i
anyway
i really thought
two-parter what is the name of the
captain's yacht on the enterprise d
mikey
i think i know i know this is wrong now
i've written it but for some reason i've
got the name sherberg in my head
no don't know where you got that one
from space
was it and this this could be me being
completely wrong was it the hms gilbert
and sullivan
no
oh where did i get no but i know where
you're coming from you're not actually
million miles away but you i know where
you're coming from
i have no idea i might i wrote d minus
one
so do you have any answer for the e
because i do actually name it
in the film
no the answer for the d i put up e minus
one
the calypso is the name of the captain's
yacht according to patrick stewart in
the enterprise d
and on the enterprise e it is the
cousteau
i knew it was something french that's
why i wrote sherberg
oh i got mixed up because they were
singing gilbert and sullivan they were
still singing songs
um i forget why it's called the cousteau
and the clip so it's to do the writers
and it's impactful suits favorite
writers or something and he uh he got to
basically name it
so according to data in data's day how
many species are represented on
enterprise d we'll get a point for the
closest so take a stab in the dark
mike
436
436 on there's only a crew of a thousand
okay uh captain spencer
350
350 okay
stormy this was speed different species
right not species okay
37 species
stormy is going to get the point again
but you are it's 13
species i'm singing okay i yeah i got
confused with the federation there for a
second
yeah how many well it's only 100 um
members of the federation
more species they've encountered more
species than that though as as the
federation
yeah but they had to be a member of then
you have to
you didn't have to be a member of the
federation today you didn't have to
that's why wolf is such an unusual thing
isn't it because he became but anyway
um 13 is what he says in the answer so
how long is the enterprise e
closest wins
mike come on
350 meters
350 meters
stormy
200 meters
no
and spence i put that it was three
movies long
[Laughter]
good effort because it was mikey you're
gonna get the points but you're actually
only got half an enterprise
um
that's what they all say 5.7 meters is
the is the correct length what what was
the correct length
685.
and the enterprise a and the jj abrams
um is actually bigger it's over 700
meters
um but uh that's what i can get a bonus
point
somehow i got two points in that round i
don't know quite how but i did
stormy got five points
the stormy might have actually took the
lead around
[ __ ] me
well my parents think the story not the
technical specs
spence you have got seven points out of
a possible back 25
stormy you've got nine yeah and mikey
you have four points so you know still
still within touching distance you need
one good round to make one i've got five
points
where have you got a fifth one from
all right in the first round i've got
three points i'm not gonna argue with
you oh yeah you did actually you're
right didn't i have a hand thank you
very much
i just gave you a four point storm and i
was feeling generous
so the movies
well we got the uh the wrong answers
only first uh how were the borg defeated
following the battle of
sector 001 give us your answers at the
end for a bonus point
in the movies
where was the enterprise d destroyed
where
and i'm saying it was i know the
engine section was destroyed in orbit
and then
uh the saucer wasn't salvaged so we're
gonna say it was destroyed
where
and i will take the system or the planet
name
how many decks does the enterprise e
have
question number three
okay
it's only writing a number
two questions again
okay
got an answer
i think i'm wrong
okay
okay there was that one then there was
that one okay i'm good again
what would the crew most about riker and
troy's wedding on betazoid beta zed
sorry
sorry what
what worried the crew the most
about the wedding of riker and troy on
beta z
drop off the pen
is that question four question three
that's question three
thank you
we all know that come on
you best
number four
what is the highest grossing tng movie
that is movie that the next generation
crew appear in
this is according to imdb
is this suggested for inflation
yes
and it is gross over its entire lifetime
but it also had the highest opening
weekend
this next question's a bastard
i'm so sorry
but it means me when it when i found it
name at least two of picard's imaginary
children from the nexus
and i'll give you a clue there's five
kids
so
two sons and three daughters
you know i think i've done it
anyway if you get all five i'll give you
a bonus point
that ain't happening
i didn't think it would
i can barely spell my own name these
days
don't blame me
it's underrated
give me a nod when you're ready
question number six
who accompanied kirk aboard the
enterprise b inspection at the start of
generations
who accompanied who
kirk
i think back to the right uh the the
character names right yeah the character
names
will you accept jeff bezos
yes he had his penis-shaped ship
you know that they're going to build a
space station is it going to be vagina
shaped
i hope so
it's got to be in it
that's very egalitarian isn't it
yeah have you seen that um that part of
austin powers where
dr eagle sends up his rocket
yeah
that's exactly
yeah
a bald evil fella
sorry jeff we do pay our subscriptions
yes i do
i'm a sap i pay for all this stuff
such a loser
anyway
question number seven
name humanity's first warp capable ship
it's been a long
i can draw it i can draw a picture of it
the name what is the name of zefron
cochrane's
warp capable [ __ ] i wrote zephyr and
cochrane hoping i'd get a bonus point so
that's that gone if i draw a picture of
it does that count
come on you should know the name it's
symbolic
that's a clue come on it's symbolic
jesus i've seen first contact so many
times this is what i mean i focus on the
story not the two
what does picard use to kill a borg on
the hollow deck
in first contact
what does picard use to kill a borg
on the hollow deck in first contact
the [ __ ] was it
oh oh in first contact right right right
disengage safety protocols have a blast
right it was uh
the only film with the borg in it
that is true
redundant saying first contact really
wasn't but
trying to help can i help
this is question eight
this is question number eight oh god i'm
pissed off about that
that freaking warp drive craft
[Laughter]
i know it it's there it's
all right
would you two like to be alone
questions
right what did david say he could be
used as
in case they crashed in water
in insurrection
he was designed that he could be used as
a what
[Applause]
if bev's asking the question of whistle
if tasha yar's asking questions it could
be bloody anything isn't it
three vibration settings
and finally question number ten
who directed star trek insurrection
who directed
i'm annoying spencer will know this and
i have no idea
okay so the wrong only answers
okay how were the ball defeated
following the battle of sector zero zero
one
anybody got an idea
wrong answers only
i put bad writing
wd-40 overdose
just just literally slipped off the
balconies
it's sailing right off into the vacuum
hell of a first step monkey
i put acid in a good brush
that is the bonus
mikey gets the bonus on that one
okay
so
to the answers
in the movies
where was the enterprise d destroyed at
the end of generations
mike
was on that forest planet wouldn't it
endor
yeah that one you know that one
so you don't know
it's not porous planet you know here's
our first planet
yeah captain spencer have you got a name
for that first place
on the planet
on the planet excellent
stormy have you watched star trek
generations okay it was the planet
orbiting the star soaring try to destroy
system and the planet was viridian 3.
oh i knew that
you should have known that do you know
where right
hey do you know where that was filmed i
know where that scene was filmed
on the floor
everything was filmed in canada it was
uh filmed in uh uh owens valley the
alabama hills of california okay it's a
shame between them remember what the
planet was called in it so that was good
i don't know yeah but i can find uh you
know it was viridian
i just told you that
all right
how many decks does the enterprise e
have according to canon
42
no
stormy
58.
and spence i put 60
no
weirdly
so like put your miseries that this was
the trick question
bump up bam so you've all missed out
your bonus points
picard says that there are 24 decks of
the enterprise e that's why i said 24 in
the last round
weirdly much smaller in height at least
than the enterprise d but then wharf
says that the borg stopped on deck 26 so
there's then all suddenly at least 26
decks
the schematic in the background when
picard is telling uh i can't remember
name i heard that there's 24 decks only
shows 23 decks
um in
um
the other star wars movie uh the last
one oh it's gonna have my head
the others
star trek
nemesis riker says he's going to go down
because the riemanns have invaded the
ship and he's going to go down to deck
39 to beat one up and then there's a
massive endless chasm that he throws the
riemann into so apparently there's 39
plus a bottomless pit at the bottom of
the enterprise
so
24 23 26 or flip nose
loads
depending on the answer
but the official answer because picard
is always right he's 24.
i said 24 in the last one but
he doesn't have 24.
i'm gutted
so you missed out your bonuses there
what would the crew most about riker and
troy's wedding on betazoid
specificity
stormy
nudity
nudity
circumcised we all want to know
it's it's what interested people want to
know did you get that mic
they did yes i got liberty yeah good
i know he loves a bit of nudity as soon
as they mention nudity he's like
we can see that bit
um what is the highest grossing tng
movie
spikes stormy
first contact
suspense
first contact
and mikey
i also put first contact
you are all correct
you have the highest opening weekend in
the united states and that was the
highest grossing movie i love that i
cheered but also that invalidates any of
the points because it's just put us all
an even kill correct yeah exactly
um name at least two of picard's
children imaginary children in the nexus
this might be this might be my weird
brain but
is one of them called bobby
nope
okay the other one sally
no
okay wrong ignore me
excellent anybody anybody get any
answers i oh storm you go
go there
i think i remember one and it seems like
one was named robert
after his
nephew no but there is an interesting
point it wasn't robert but the actor
that played
um one of the boys so i won't tell you
is the same actor that paid repair
who is his brother's son yeah that's
where i go
i also put roberta did you yeah but but
i also put renee
no but you're not far off
his imaginary children who are all named
in the movie uh matthew and thomas for
the boys
olivia mimi and madison are his
daughters
no points
the interesting point of talking about
his children is in in a light his son
was played by his real son in real life
i yeah i told that actually yeah yeah he
was played by um
i can't remember his name but yeah his
his
patrick stewart's real son played his
son in like bobby stewart we'll go with
that um renee stuart robert stewart
reverse stewart
back in the 70s i could see him i could
see him yet
jackie stewart
formula one quiz next week guys oh good
i'll do that i'm not
um i wouldn't be and i just fall asleep
and say oh they've gone around again
watching star trek
yeah we could do a man united meeting
spurs um quitters that would be a good
one three now come on
no question number six who accompanied
kirk aboard the enterprise b inspection
at the beginning of generations
and everything was installed on tuesday
and everything was installed stormy who
accompanied him
oh i've got it wrong
check chekhov and scotty
you are correct but there was actually
only two bones didn't go it was
checker for scotty so spence
oh i i literally don't even remember
that but i wrote sulu
which is
embarrassing you see what i did there
they spent this i don't know how my mind
went there mm-hmm
you can't name too many people in the
first
capable vessel
that's all i'll look stupid about
question six but question seven i know
the answer to hit it mikey
it was the phoenix i don't know why i
started calling you mikey by the way
that's just started and i've just
carried on we'll go with it
phoenix
storms
and spencer
i wrote thanks for nothing jay
that's not the name of the ship i'm
afraid sir but
hey it's not far off
if you do this
phoenix if you're gonna go thanks for
nothing phoenix
right question number eight what does
picard use to kill a borg on the
holodeck
a garment
tommy gun gun atomic specifically atomic
i'm afraid because it is very clearly a
tommy gun what
yeah will you not accept my
oh it's obviously i'll tell you what
i'll give you half a point because it is
a gun but i think
it's important it was a tommy gun
anything could be a gun
if you put your mind to it
yeah
okay
does he deserve a point remembering
i'll give him a point
okay so what did data say he could be
used as in case they crashed into water
what was he designed to be used as mike
a flotation device
spence
a floatation device
and stormy
search and rescuer
unlucky it is a flotation device
such a weird line that whole bit was so
weird the whole film was weird yeah and
crap but anyway who directed star trek
insurrection who directed it
i think i'm wrong but i've put freaks
i put frank's as well and stormy
you were all correct it was jonathan
okay so at the end of that round mike
you got seven points
storm you've got six points
and spence you've got five points
that's not too bad
not too bad
looking good i'm happy with that that's
what that's right
no one asked me how many meters and such
and such and such and such
or how deep did it look cling on latrine
or any of that kind of stuff
so we're at the moment
spencer you were on 17 points
it goes man
stormy you're on 19 points
and mike you're on 15 points all right
guys
um ask more questions
ask more plot questions
who is the captain of the boseman ask me
that
he was the captain the
bozeman fraser
what was the actress what was the um
captain's healthy grandma
what was the captain's name and he was
captain morgan batesman he was kevin
nolan basically you know
well done
do you know what
i lost the questions today that was
originally a question no
oh
and i lost the question so i had to
write them all again and i didn't think
about
it
i would have got that i love that
episode that's a good episode in it
um okay so
the next round is general sci-fi but the
last
wrong answer is only in what
circumstances is it okay to breach the
prime directive and i'll ask your
answers
at the end
so here we go general sci-fi so this is
going to be questions on anything that
popped into my stupid little brain
and here we go in star wars who raised
star wars
i know this is on anything mate this is
on anything is no way okay so we are
this is this is a star wars question not
a star trek question this is general
sci-fi
i'm expecting a baby
in star wars who raised luke with uncle
owen
oh brilliant answer sorry
who played the seventh doctor
oh [ __ ] off got it
[Laughter]
i know you'd be after that
thanks jay
you got my back
i
really
doctor who with all my passion
do you love dr hay
i'm ashamed to know you
true or false
the firefly appeared in battlestar
galactica
true or false
and that is the
the firefly vessel
that is question three here
i never watched it
again i don't know who you are anymore
the balsa ball but particularly the mini
series
is phenomenal
you've never seen it i will though got a
bit bored of the series afterwards right
here
question number four
heuristically programmed
heuristically programmed algorithic
computer album
heuristically programmed algorithmic
computer is better known as what
heuristically programmed algorithmic
computer is better known as what
stormy nose
i actually know what the the successor
to that was but we're not going to talk
about that excellent
question number five the jupiter mining
corporation operated which classic
vessel
the jupiter mining corporation operated
which classic vessel
storm has got an excuse not to know this
but you two have no excuse
got it
sorry it took me a tip me five seconds
we're good
excellent am i missing something
yeah you've never seen it
have you never seen it my god right
anyway
i'm guessing
a blade run a question blade runner is
loosely based on which novel
yeah
read it
there's a bonus question i'm still
writing
sorry sir dear god
don't you annoy the american
napalmus
i don't know if this was it or um
is this question seven one now
no we're on the ground question question
question
procedure
who did not attend the 1977 star wars
premiere and new hope you get a bonus
question if you tell me what you did
instead
what so sorry question 7 is who didn't
attend the premiere question 7 who did
not attend the 1977 star wars premiere a
new hope
you get a bonus point sorry if you can
tell me what he did instead
okay
question number eight
how many times did vin vin diesel record
the line i am groot
for the guardians of the galaxy movie
is it once
ten times
a thousand times
ten thousand times
he never said it at all
so how many times do you actually record
the line i am groot the guardians of the
galaxy once tense ten times
roughly a thousand times roughly ten
thousand times or he didn't
question number nine has three parts
you'll get one point if you can get two
of them
you'll get two points you can get all
three
what were robocop's prime directives
and this is before we got reprogrammed
another million from the original movie
what was robocop's prime directives
one point for two two points for all
three
do you get two points for two
no
one point two
two points for all three
um
one off
it's the middle one everyone always
forgets the middle one
i'm probably so far afield of that i'm
not even funny
i've not i've never watched it so
you've never watched robocop are you
joking me man no
okay okay okay
three prime directives
so i'm promising peter weller or the
robber the proper version peter what was
his name robert um
it was actually it was the same guy from
a stephen king
thinner film played robocop in robocop
3. i can't remember his name robert oh
yeah i have seen that but now i know it
costs the first one is watchable
is that question number 10
who is the only person to have ever
played himself
on star trek the next generation
i thought that ends the quiz on a star
trek question
but who's the only person who have ever
played himself
on star trek the next generation you're
not going to drop it this time it's
winston
no because i realized that i got
question four wrong and i don't know the
answer and that's the babylon five
question
isn't it
question number four
yeah now question four is heuristically
programmed algorithmic computers better
known as
oh
there isn't another one five questions
no there isn't he's it's in the video
we're going to get in a second there's a
bubble on top i'm sorry oh
oh my god
i thought there was only four rounds
now there's a bonus video around
and this is the one that mikey's not
looking forward to
great okay
right let's do
everything
we will do the answers and then we will
do the video around oh okay um and then
we will
have a little chat while we're trying to
figure out the video around answers
so when is the prime directive when is
it okay to breach the prime directive
wrong answers only
star track i would say
it's okay to breach for prime
directive all the time
that is the correct answer though that's
not that's not the wrong answer
whenever the bloody hell they like
kirk was memory suits
if you happen to captain the voyager
yeah or the original enterprise
um but stormy that answer
when the condom fails
someone's getting this one mikey that's
gonna have to be great are you sure
that's just tea in that flask storm
no i put here
during brexit negotiations
i do a brexit negotiations
stormy's getting it though i'm sorry but
mikey you're really close love you mike
there was nothing in there
okay so in star wars who raised luke
with uncle owen it
was spencer barulas
i'll take out peru mike
his wife
his wife excellence correct stormy
spence if you can give me her actual
full name i'll give you a bonus point
aunt barulas
so nearly
it was ann's white sun lars her maiden
name was white sun
question number two who played the
seventh doctor
spence sylvester mccoy
stall
who are technically attempted as the
11th doctor but sylvester
he also played radagast
he did radagast for brown i know right
when i figured it out it was just like i
i just i had it
wow i had to go take a drink or
something i mean that was the one
question i was actually most worried
about i'm really i'm glad you gave me
the answer that i've got because i think
there's going to be some sort of stupid
argument on why it's not who that person
anyway no it doesn't get complex until
the ninth doctor
where's the north africa the war doctor
when they start jumping back
between the eighth and the ninth
question number three firefly appeared
in battle star galactica true or false
mike
true
spence
false
storm
false
unless there was like some little
colonial
something something that was in that
[ __ ] convoy that was getting firefly
true
i knew there was that question
i thought you thrown it as a joke
no
it's they shared a um the company that
did the special effects from a boat did
both series
and in the um original mini series while
they're actually on the planet i think
it's caprica
um they the firefly flies overhead it is
not one of the ships from the armada
it flies overhead
so they threw in as a little ammar
little easter egg
as well mike's the only person who
hasn't seen that show
best complete guess well evidently some
of the the cylons did take the sky from
them
yes they just say i miss fireflies so
this is the story of my life
yeah i've watched firefly three times
since it's a bit on disney i've sweated
three times now it's only been about six
weeks
um anyway can we can i do a request
actually
can we do a full quiz on the orville at
some point yeah i'll do that yeah i love
the orville
i've just started watching it so
we'll we'll do an oval series when
series three comes out sorry
for fun
um
have heuristically programmed
algorithmic computer is better known as
stormy
hal
mike
i've got robocop
okay spence
dude i was way out on this i'm not even
gonna
no okay
i'll just
the the
the the successor for how the next
generation computer was
sal wow
um
university of illinois wasn't it
yeah i think so yeah
so yeah it's actually the high nine
thousand it was 2001 space odyssey
obviously the jupiter mining corporation
operated which classic vessel
spence you got this
the red dwarf the red dwarf
classic
no stormy
red
[Music]
[Applause]
he was on the wrong side of the bloody
ocean he still got
it blade runner was loosely based on
which novel
stormy
wait spence i know you've got it
stormy
no
do androids dream of electric sheep
stormy
you're storming it
mike did you get an answer
i was kind of hoping that there was
going to be a kind of novel called 2047
or something ridiculous but no
no it wasn't that sad
of course the classic philip k dick
novel will do android stream of electric
sheep
fantastic well done
and number seven who did not attend the
1977 star wars premiere
and a bonus if you can tell me why or
what he did instead i should say
mike harrison ford coke binge
probably but no that's not the correct
answer so stormy
um
it was i don't know what the what other
show he was filming at the time
i don't know what answer
no i'm afraid that's not enough you mean
the actor um alec guinness no i'm afraid
that's not correct either spencer
david prowse
nope
i'm afraid the answer is actually george
lucas
did not attend the premiere
of um star wars 97 he was so convinced
it was going to be a massive flop
he went on holiday with steven spielberg
instead
and during that holiday they came up
with the idea for raiders of the lost
okay that's amazing i didn't know that
okay so how many times did vin diesel
record the line i am groot for the
guardians of the galaxy one ten roughly
a thousand roughly ten thousand or he
didn't
mike
wants
stormy
around a thousand
and kate and mr spencer it was it was it
was closer to ten thousand because vin
diesel recorded the dialogue of for i am
groot in every language it was it was a
thousand but you are correct why oh i i
am too high
in loans
for that
oh
i am tempted to give you half a point
because you didn't know why he did it i
knew why it was there he did he recorded
it for all the different languages he
did it lots of different styles he did
it roughly a thousand times
i'm going to give you a little just
cuz they're not just running through
google translate or something they could
have just not done it couldn't they
really it's just he's just saying i am
grouped for god's sake if you hear that
you know for every minute of film you
have one uh page of script
so
guardians of the galaxy v uh volume ones
was what oh roughly
two hours so you're looking at 120
120 pages so was he saying it more than
you know to get all of those variations
he'd have to get a recording studio and
go one i don't know how many languages
there are i'm not a geography guy it
will be listed in the in the uh
if you watch it online or like disney
plus and watch the extended credits
it'll list all the voice actors for
everything and all the other different
talking of vin diesel though last night
i watched a very very good film on
netflix with vin diesel and it called
bloodshot
i enjoyed that
quite i don't know you actually really
enjoyed it yeah i quite do that that's
good so it's not bad it was
it was very
bond and it was also very fast and
furious because there's lots of cars in
it i mean it bombed it tanked it didn't
do very well but they released it
literally just before um
so that's probably all the reason why it
absolutely smashed yeah it didn't do
very well
but anyway i thought it was really good
anyway yeah i enjoy it i thought it i
love the special effects
so name robocop's prime directives one
point for two three points uh two points
in all three mikey
i think i've put forward i put make
america great again i think that's wrong
though isn't it yeah that's it's so
great
it's so close
spence
what you got uphold the law protect the
innocent
yeah i was right
but i can't remember the third objective
no it's always the uh actually that's
not the one i thought you'd get wrong
books storm you got anything
serve protected in force i may be
thinking about the law protect the
innocent
i can't give you a point for that one
then but it's it's serve the public
trust
protect the innocent
uphold the law
who appeared as himself in star trek for
the next generation only acted over to
have done it who was it
it's horrible
hawking
yeah
kevin hawking mike i got that right yep
fantastic guys well done right so while
i tally up those points
um it's not gonna take me very long to
count up mics
and um
it'll take me so i got two right in that
round you did very well right one of
them one of them was the star trek one
and the other one was a multiple choice
of two
which is the first series you've never
seen
i'm about to play you a video in that
video
there are five characters from tv series
you can name the character
and the actress
can you
can you repeat all that again please in
the next video i'm about to show you
okay there are i'm hopefully going to
show you there are five characters from
classic sci-fi tv shows
if you can name the character
and the actor
that is a point each
there are also
five star trek vessels you have to name
the class of the vessel not the ship
itself the class
okay so there is impossible i hope it's
in like a two second video i'll miss
having no no you will see each character
and each ship twice
okay so we'll give you the opportunity
so you're gonna see uh 20 images
okay
so there's five class of ship
five actors and their character
all right
um
i'm just gonna play it
see how you get on
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that was a confusing mess i didn't have
to mix it up
i had to watch it off of it
ah oh god
score it's even worse i can play it
again would you like to see it again
no thank you
the music responder right
i forgot to top up the answers while we
were
doing that so
i can have a minute while we just do
this
[Music]
i am so blanking on the names
i yeah i'm utterly
i'm not going to get any points
you don't know the first woman
no you're kidding
i was born in 1987 jay yeah but you can
still
get sexually aroused by a sci-fi
character i mean and i was born six days
later
really
stormy knows
he obsessed
would you guys like to throw out some of
the starship classes and see how many
points you can get
first
i can shout random starship classes at
you if you'd like
which ones did you see
oh uh
wait let me i didn't realize we could
just shout random answers out i think
that well i'd love to see what you've
written but you'll have to be honest
about what you've written so mike throw
one out
galaxy class
no the galaxy class does not appear in
that video
okay constitution class
nope
okay
with that then
i've written constitution for every
answer so
stormy did you recognize any of them
i mean it was i got i saw the name a car
and i said what [ __ ] show was that on
and it's just
i put a scientific class
oh god
right the first ship that we see is the
miranda class that is the vessel that um
from wrath of khan
khan
talk and thing and it's seen multiple
occasions during the star trek
universe even into tng
the second
starship we see is the ambassador class
which is the enterprise b and that is
the one that i think you think is the
galaxy
um it is very similar lines
the third class we see because it says
it on the whole is the akira class
okay i got one i just but i did say
akira so i'm going to give you one point
stormy
um vessel that we see uh
is the prometheus and the prometheus
class
yeah i know you hated voyager mike but
it's quite a good episode
and the last vessel that we saw is the
nova class and that was seen in the last
double voyager episode the uh
the forge captained i think
uh no not laforge it was um no no the
forge captain won in mid-season
now harry was the captain of the nova
scotia i will argue though as much as i
saw i hated voyager my two favorite trek
episodes of any series happened in
voyager
year of hell
year of however
you
yeah
yeah i love the scorpion episodes i love
the scorpion episode i love the two last
two episodes i thought the last two
episodes of voyager and the actual are
probably the only time except maybe if
the tng the last two episodes of tng
were good that actually they've ended on
a decent
like
i liked the fluidic space arc with yeah
speed species seven three one was it
three four seven two three four yeah
there you go yeah yeah yeah um those are
good i love that team up with the
starting to realize i'm more of a star
trek geek than i thought
i think i might want to i'm not i'm not
a voyager geek i'm a big next-gen ds9
geek but
well we'll see if your scores
back that up
so
who's the first character that we see
oh the first character first young lady
that we see very pretty young lady
guessing that's stormy
just the character right character it's
the character on the actress uh oh
barbarella jane fonda
barbarella james fonda
correct you guys didn't get that at all
you've never seen barbarella not even in
like a poster
wow okay you guys didn't have the
vietnam war so everybody knows [ __ ]
jane fonda
who is the character from stargate that
we see
second person we see
i don't like stargate
never watched it
from stargate
yes
she is the very pretty lady she was also
in firefly but i'm looking for the
stargate character
um she is the [ __ ]
firefly
in stargate her name was adria
does anybody know the actresses now
audrey okay well so uh i i know the
actress's name maria
who is the first male
actor that we see
i'll be honest the order threw me out
it does throw i was trying to confuse
you i was trying to throw you out i have
to admit
there was one that would be too easy
there was a brian blessed in there
somewhere brian blessed what character
did he play
hawk man
oh come on
why don't you get a point
okay so the first actor i remember from
the sequence
act or the male
uh was the jerry doyle that was playing
gareth baldy from babylon 5. you get two
points for that
he wasn't he was um second but that
doesn't matter i just wrote babble on
five guy because i haven't seen it in
years but no points for me michael
mirabaldi mr gara baldi
yeah everyone else had a rank except for
gary baldwin who's always just missing
mikey did you get airballed
no
mike's never seen babylon 5.
oh my god you've got to go watch battle
r5 man
i thought this is the star trek quiz
i don't know about it
sci-fi round i didn't tell you but
anyway
right so can anybody remember listed
brian blessed character from flash
gordon
i got brian blessed as an actor by the
way i didn't i did write about that
i didn't know what from beard
guy with beat he's always got a beat
i didn't know who the [ __ ] out was i
just wrote down gimli
his character is prince voltan
of course
and did you see the other character from
babylon 5 uh yes i did mike you should
know the actor
i'll give you a hint mike i had dinner
with him once
sushi greensboro north carolina
really yeah sure did with what actor
mike what's his name
oh no idea oh storm ah walter koenig
walter koenig and what character do you
play in babylon 5
one of the best go on there stormy
bester
faster [ __ ] low life i need to
re-watch that show what bones
best drawer b-e-s-t
he was the head of the psycho
really bad dude and he played a
brilliant bad guy he was absolutely
fantastic
right
i have some final scores
all right
i have
being british
i'm ashamed of you is this going to be a
metric
no this is just going to be in really
low points initially
with 18 points
mike
you've let us down you have a beard and
everything i thought you were going to
smash this
you could you need to grow the beard out
into a point like
stormy and you'd have done better
but you didn't completely let us down
captain spencer
with 24 and a half points
but
with the mightiest beard
and the most brilliant and uh admiral
stormy apparently if we're going to go
by frank
with 34 points
absolutely smashed it the americans come
in oh my
days 34.
out of a possible
oh well there is that
that's 60 points
yeah but um
very well done storming thank you thank
you thank you thank you thank you and um
and i i had a real thing trying to get
this quiz right trying to make it not
too difficult and not too hard and
apparently i made it way too hard you
made it way way too hard
but i had fun doing it
and then i had fun doing it again today
because i couldn't remember remember i
put the questions
two weeks ago for a while on holiday
so
how have you enjoyed that guys
yeah it was funny learned something that
was fun i learned that mike is not gimli
but we will do a quiz on
um thingy next i think so actually i
think um series three of orville's quite
soon i'll have to double check but um i
think it's the next couple of months
so maybe before christmas we'll do in an
orville and i've just started watching
orville again as well so um i've started
watching it so i'm quite enjoying it
actually i will focus on uh
story
for those questions all right spence
might be okay with you what actually
happens
with species
freaking laser beams come out of their
head
that's a great episode that
all right so you haven't got to that
point yet might kill me
no no not quite yet but we always truly
sometimes spencer and i work together
sometimes we are set in the office some
days
and he with complete silence because
it's only him and i in the office and he
will turn to me to go do you remember
when picard did this this this and this
and i'll stare at him and go
yeah
and that'll be
we'll just get into a discussion for
about half an hour about tmg and then go
out to work
god i wish i worked with you guys
because i don't i don't get anybody to
talk to about star trek anymore
all we do is talk about star trek
okay 100 advertising and advertising 100
of our workforce love tng
excellent
i wish you loved it a bit more because
you might got a better score and beat
the america
you should have rather technical manuals
mate
i go ready
i got the most points on the technical
round you did you did very well i
remember
i watched a video a while ago and said
did you know there was dolphins on the
enterprise and i'm like oh yeah because
i read the technical manual i knew that
that looks like
i'm such a sad loser i really am but um
anyways we're all online with our
friends on halloween having a load of
fun
exactly
and spencer you're still sober so you've
not fallen over
you've not drawn permanent ink on
yourself that's this is a victory i was
i was really tempted to do trill
markings again and then i was like
i was like nah
that's played out that's played out oh
i'll come at me i'll come with like a
klingon like head gear next time head
gear next time okay then guys
i will look forward to our
orville video
when we do that that'll be a lot of fun
and thanks guys and
put the comments on tell us what scores
you got you definitely got better than
mike
um and see if anybody's beat stormy uh i
will throw on a few little uh
hip hip arrays to anybody who's done
well so thank you guys thank you stormy
i enjoyed it thank you for having me
cheers guys please go find aliens and
stuff and go find styleworks um i
haven't put the link in the description
because i forgot but i will straight
after the video go and subscribe to
channels they talk about loads of
interesting things and
guys thank you for joining us we'll see
you next time i so enjoyed it fellas
cheers guys thank you guys have a good
night yes bye